i wanted to know if you don't mind
sharing a little bit about your
unplugging and basically what does
unplugging mean for you
okay so um
it's part of the title of the book that
i wrote called the unplugged alpha on
amazon and um
it like it started with the notion of
unplugging and taking the red pill but i
but i feel it it needs a much broader
application because too much of that
part of the youtube and internet focuses
way too much on uh women
um i've been quoted many times as saying
chase excellence not women that doesn't
mean just chase excellence and not
understand women but the process of
unplugging
i mean there's you know if you take a
wagon wheel like a big wheel there's
several spokes to it it's not just one
spoke and if one spoke is the only thing
connecting the the hub to the edge of
the wheel you're not gonna have a very
effective wheel
if you have
two or three more let's say it's
slightly more effective but it's still
not what it needs to be to to stand up
to proper use right it's going to
collapse eventually so
when i'm talking to guys about
unplugging i mean let's just take five
let's say there's seven eight or ten
spokes of this wheel but let's just take
five main ones just so we can give our
audience something to
chew on um
let's start with the red pill part right
because what that deals with is seeing
what women really respond to right
versus what we've been told that they
respond to we've been told be a nice guy
be humble you know become less so she
could become more
blah blah blah all of these narratives
and what guys typically find if you know
they become the nice guy is they just
get used they just get treated like an
emotional tampon
um
you know she'll she'll she'll cry to the
nice guy about you know the things going
on in the world and then go and bang mr
exciting bad boy sort of thing right
that's that's just how women are wired
to operate and that changes you know
throughout time depending on how old
they are and even where they are in
their mental cycle during the month so
just one spoke of the wheel
involves dealing with what women
actually respond to which is more or
less you know what the red pill summed
up as as it's known today
but you really have to broaden that
right because there's so much more to it
you know to understand like you're a fit
guy obviously so we can deal with
something like self-care
and self-care to me isn't just looking
fit and being strong and living in a
masculine body i mean i've done that my
entire life
um at my age i'm still fitter than
probably 99 of guys right now i mean
most of them couldn't do
30 push-ups 10 cent ups and skip broke
for two minutes straight it's just and
that's asking way too much of guys today
right so
just just being fit and living in a
healthy body and being strong is one
thing good you can deadlift so what you
can squat okay you can throw in a few
plates and bench can you fight though
right so there's a there's a competency
element you know that needs to be built
into
self-care right what if somebody breaks
in your house and what if you live
somewhere where you don't have a weapon
or you're traveling and you don't have a
weapon to defend yourself can you use
your fists can you fight right so i mean
like you know you have to broaden the
scope of of plugged in versus unplugged
and i think that when you're unplugging
you're unplugging in a lot of different
errors in your life and seeing things as
they really are i mean let's talk about
money next right that's an important one
i mean
a lot of people don't have a good
relationship with money meaning they're
either carrying way too much debt
they went to post-secondary education
and uh racked up 1500 200 000 worth of
student loan debt and they don't really
have
a foreseeable way out of it that could
be one thing it could be consumer credit
card debt because they were told that
they were richer than they thought they
were and they took on credit facilities
that they couldn't afford to pay off
which are essentially designed to keep
you in a perpetual cycle of being in
debt so when you deal with the money
component of it
um you know i believe that when you
unplug from the notion of what money
really is it's it's a store of value
that creates freedom for people
right when you've got
access to financial resources you can
throw that at some serious problems in
the world you can also refuse to do
things that you don't want to do that
might compromise compromise your core
values you know if somebody were to say
to me hey rich you know there's this big
paying project you know
whatever
let's say a podcasting company said to
me hey rich and i'll give you a hundred
million dollars to do this podcast on
this platform only if it's not aligned
with me
and i've already got money i'm just
gonna tell them to pound sand because
i'm not interested i don't care how much
money it is because i'm anti-fragile and
i don't need it right so when it comes
to money it's not just you know
buying the you know proverbial
you know white picket fence home
having the station wagon in a driveway
with the 2.1 kids and a fluffy dog money
is is a lot more than just paying your
mortgage and putting a roof over your
head and food in your stomach
it's a store of value that's very useful
for for solving problems
and if you're going to acquire fu money
you really need to have fu skills too
right which most people don't understand
you know which ties into the competency
thing so in my second book like i'm
diving into a lot of those concepts to
really expand on a lot a lot further but
the process of unplugging is really
unplugging from comforting lies that
you've been sold your entire life
and plugging into uncomfortable truths
of things and far far too many people
just nod their head and they're like yes
we'll comply master and we'll just you
know stand in line they're all npcs
right they're just sheep marching into a
slaughterhouse is what it is
do you think that the unplugged alpha
and some of the terms there
apply to females as well and some of
this unplugging process can also benefit
females
and if not why
i talk to men
okay
do
do women watch my material yeah about
ten percent of my audience on my youtube
channel is women right yeah you can go
see it as entrepreneurs and cars um
i've seen women read my book and leave
female reviews most of it is quite
positive
um but i deal with men right and it's
not that i don't deal with women or i
don't want to deal with amendment i've
done
probably a handful i can get them on one
or two hands i've done well over a
thousand consults privately you know
with people
um for coaching but i've talked to a few
women um can women unplug the way that
men can sure but women are totally
different in their thinking they come
from a more
emotional perspective and women also put
a lot more trust and
i don't even know if trust is a right
word but women get duped a lot
easier by big state and daddy government
than than what i see men getting duped
you know so
um can they unplug absolutely it's it's
seeing seeing the seeing the reality of
the world for what it is is is not an
easy thing to do otherwise more guys
would be unplugged i mean if i were to
estimate it i'd say probably less than
five to ten percent of the populations
actually understands what's really going
on in the world most people just
sleepwalk through life uh men and women
inclusive it's just you know it is what
it is
you